Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts
of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining
us on our first episode.
On the first official episode, right?
Thank you for the BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning
is a short format morning show
held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO.
And hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a
smile to your face and
help you start off your
day on the right paw.
Please make sure to tweet your thoughts
with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
- FUWAMOCO Morning.
- Right above us.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand
new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Well, maybe we'll jump right into things.
What's this? What's this? What's this?
We just reached 700,000
views on our cover of Kaibutsu!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I'm really really happy that you
have been enjoying it so much.
Do you have any favorite parts?
Moco-chan, do you have a favorite part?
- I like the beginning too.
- The beginning?
There's a part in the very very
beginning, Moco-chan, that you sing,
that your voice gets all like...
- I like that part.
- What part is that?
Subarashiki sekai e...
I'm not too sure.
You have to listen closely, Ruffians.
It'll be in the first couple seconds.
We've seen in the comments that a lot
of listeners seem to hear Marine-senpai.
Marine-senpai... Last time I checked,
she's... She's not part of FUWAMOCO.
Unfortunately, she's not.
But it makes us happy that you
would compliment us that way because
we very much love Marine-senpai
and Marine-senpai's voice.
Big compliment.
She wants to apply!
What would her name be?
I don't know if Lui-senpai
would be okay with that.
But would you like to hear more songs?
More cover songs from us?
What would you like to hear?
There's a lot of really good
songs so it's hard to decide.
Actually, it did take us quite a while
to decide which song we wanted
- to pick for our very first cover.
- It's difficult, y'know?
There's so many good songs.
Right, you know?
And they can show all different
types of you, so, you know?
There's those kind
of ways to enjoy it too.
300! 300 of them. Ohh!
Idol by YOASOBI-san.
Are we gonna be stuck
just to YOASOBI songs?
That's not too bad though...
Ah, Tuning Love?
Tuning Love's cute too.
Lots of good suggestions.
Kagamine Twins.
We definitely didn't
have that thought too.
But thank you so much for listening to it.
We hope that you continue to
enjoy it more and more and more.
We can hit 1 million?
That would be a big team.
Big, big, big team.
- Let's not get ahead of ourselves.
- No, no, not yet. No.
Maybe we can in the future.
Thank you!
But next, there's been
another misunderstanding.
Misunderstanding.
I wanted to say, so last FUWAMOCO
Morning, everyone was discussing tomorrow.
And you know it.
I got confused.
Yeah, because there's a lot
of things I don't understand.
But I feel like tomorrow isn't one of them.
I just thought that, you know,
there's two popular movies right now.
So then I thought maybe
it was something from that
because there's like a
lot of things I don't know.
And the senpai members have been
sending us a lot of things I don't know.
So I thought, but maybe it's from the
movies or maybe it was from Die Hard.
Since I've never seen that
movie and people like it.
It seems sort of like something
that would be in Die Hard.
But no, Moco-chan, you're just like
"I don't know," lots of things,
so it's probably not that, right?
- Right.
- Yeah.
Obviously, we really like hololive, but
It's very hard to know
everything about hololive.
But yeah, this was one of them.
Actually, actually, we took the
official hololive quiz, the hololive Kentei.
I'm not sure if you did it.
Unfortunately, you can't take it anymore.
The testing period is over.
But we wanted to share our
scores with you, you know?
hololive ID Kentei,
hololive English Kentei,
And then hololive JP Kentei.
Even the JP one in Japanese too.
We passed!
The official test.
Official test, you know.
We were really nervous about
it because they're really hard.
Really, really hard.
You know, we study up a lot.
Maybe we studied a bit too much.
But we figured, you know, this
would be the least we could do.
And obviously, by no means does
it mean that we know everything.
We don't know everything.
We don't know nothing.
We'd like to know more
too, but we're also
We're also very forgetful puppies
when we're under pressure.
So like, if you were to ask me,
Fuwawa, what are you streaming next?
I'd be like, I don't know!
Right, right.
So we have to make notes sometimes.
Alright, so more puppies, thank you!
We're pleased,
Moco-chan, we're pleased.
It was very fun though, but...
It reminded me of being back
at Guard Dog Training, right?
Right.
- It was tricky.
Tricky, tricky.
Definitely recommend if they do
hololive Kentei the official quiz again.
- Right?
- You get your certification.
- Certification.
- Yeah.
But also, there's been
another misunderstanding.
This time it wasn't Mococo.
It was me.
During our Question and Answer
stream, I picked up a comment about
Takenoko vs Kinoko, which is Takenoko's
bamboo shoots and Kinoko's mushrooms.
I thought, you know, the yummiest ones are
actual mushrooms and actual bamboo shoots.
And not the chocolate snacks, you know,
The Kinoko no Yama and Takenoko no Sato.
- She though actual ones.
- So I don't want you to misunderstand that
Our decision when it comes
to the chocolate snacks.
When it comes to the
actual vegetables, you know?
All mushrooms are good!
- We're not like Nerissa or Biboo.
- No!
- All mushrooms are delicious.
- Mushrooms are very very yummy.
But what about Nameko?
Nameko!
- It might be a bit tricky.
- Maybe it's still a bit tricky.
I like it, but it's a bit
difficult to eat a lot of them.
But to set the score right, when it comes
to the chocolate snack, we like...
Neither!
Yeah, you know it's chocolate.
The actual veggie is yummy.
I prefer to have the actual vegetables.
No chocolate. No snacks.
Got it?
- Understood?
- Understood.
That is the end of the
Takenoko vs Kinoko debate.
The misunderstanding.
It's all cleared.
We can start our day
knowing that it's all good now.
Well, today we wanted to introduce
our first thoughts about Advent.
What was it like meeting Advent?
Moco-chan prepared
something very special.
I hope you like it.
I did my best, okay?
First up, we have Shiori!
Our first thoughts of Shiori.
The first thing she said, I
remember it very clearly.
She went, Shiori!
It was really cute.
So cute that I kind of
thought like, is she joking?
It was that big of a gap!
- It's very good.
- Oh, right?
And then she was like really, really
stoic and kind of like a bit of a
hard to read ear to her, so it was a very
interesting first impression, I think.
Very like kakkoike.
Yeah.
I think to be completely honest,
we were a bit scared of her at first,
you know, especially with her
really strong piercing bird-like eyes.
But I feel like, you know,
It was a bit of a funny
feeling at first, you know?
We felt a bit troubled actually
because we wanted to get
to know Shiori better, but
we just felt like we couldn't.
Like, really like, we're like, uh, FUWAMOCO
what are we doing wrong, you know?
We would kind of think
of strategies, you know.
Things to get her
to maybe warm up to us.
- Or us to warm up to her.
- Right?
You know?
She was a really tough book to crack,
but all of a sudden, that just changed.
And we don't feel that
way anymore, you know?
Shiori's really, really sweet.
I think she definitely tries to put
on a strong face, like, I'm so cool.
But she's actually really, really sweet.
And even I feel like a
bit shy sometimes, too.
- She's really dependable.
- Dependable!
And she has so, so, so
much knowledge in that.
We wish we could
Google search her brain.
Right? She has a lot
going on in her noggin.
So, it'd be nice to search
it, but... You can't do that.
Yeah, we don't really want
to overburden her with
All our FUWAMOCO questions
and requests and stuff like that.
Yeah. And that's the other thing,
you know, if the other Advent members,
If they let us be needy,
right, we're gonna be needy.
It's not good. They need to not spoil us.
We love Shiori!
We love you Shiori!
We hope you like
Moco-chan's illustration.
I did my best. I really captured your eyes.
I think so, I think so.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Does it look just like her?
It does, right?
"Adorable?"
"It's cute?" Thank you! Thank you!
OK, well...
Next Advent member is Biboo!
I think one of the first things
she said was "I'm really shy."
But that lasted really
for about 30 minutes.
I don't think she's that shy.
Maybe she's shy like us.
Maybe.
Do you think we're shy?
I think we're shy.
Maybe we're the same kind of shy.
But she's very cute and a
very sharp rock, you know?
I think she kind of
downplays her powers.
Yeah.
You know, that makes her a bit cuter too.
But we can see through that.
And I think she's really
a master of her craft.
Yeah. I mean, she's had
years and years and years
- Right?
- To become a beautiful gem, so,
Very very sharp.
At first we were really
surprised to hear that
She likes to play games for a long
time and that's normal for her, but
We were also really happy
because we know that
FUWAMOCO, we're not
quite like that, too, so y'know
Sometimes it can be a bit tough.
It's good to have lots of different
flavors within Advent, you know?
I'm just happy that she likes it
and that she's not pushing herself.
She's definitely the gamer.
I think there was one time where
there was a reference that she wasn't
a gamer, and Biboo got
- Kinda grumpy.
- It's like "excuse me?!"
Right. Right?
She's super sweet and super
cute and. you know, she just
We get this really,
really strong feeling that
We really need to protect her extra hard.
Even though she's always
smiling, she's strong.
She's probably fine.
We worry about her, so we want
to make sure she's smiling too.
We feel very protectable.
We're protecting her smile too, sorry.
I was thinking though, you know...
Biboo has her little flaps, right?
They look kind of like ears, but...
And like, Biboo can fly too, right?
So I was thinking that... I don't
know if Biboo can do this, but
It'd be nice to kind of fly
together with Biboo's flaps.
And then like, our twin
tails could go like... Yeah.
We can fly as a group together.
I guess with Nerissa too.
Shiori can just ride on the back.
Oh really? I was gonna
say we'll make her walk.
And then Biboo's song cover, it
actually makes us really, really emotional.
I was listening to it for...
Another countless times.
And actually eating some
chicken at the same time.
And I started to get teary while I
was eating it so it was like extra salty.
If you haven't listened to it, you
need to go and listen to it, OK?
It's perfect.
- And that's Biboo.
- Biboo.
- Next is...
- Fuwawa doesn't mince words.
What did she say wrong?
What, what, what, what, what?
Did I say something wrong again?
Are we gonna have to have
another misunderstanding corner
for the next FUWAMOCO Morning?
It's just gonna be a regular corner.
It's gonna be a regular, right?
Oh well.
And last but not least...
Nerissa!
Nerissa, you know, she's...
Out of Advent, she's
definitely the lady that's
Not afraid to share what
she's passionate about.
I did a good job capturing
your likeness, right?
- She has lady lips, right?
- Yeah.
Now I'm kinda sad.
But you know, Nerissa, she also
has a bit of a baby-ness to her.
Yeah, she's a lady baby.
Lady baby.
But of course, she has
an amazing singing voice.
You know, sometimes she'll...
Sometimes? All the time!
She says, like, I'm not very good,
you know, because of my horn issue.
Her horn's hurt. It makes sense, I guess.
Yeah, you know, and she
causes damage to your mind
when she starts singing and stuff, but...
Imagine if she didn't have her horn
broken, then we'd all be done for.
- We'd be done.
- Yeah
She has her horn damaged and
yet we're all still, still like, smitten.
Addicted. Yeah.
I don't know about you, Ruffians, but...
Have you been able to get Love
Me Love Me out of your head?
Because I know that... I woke up
and it was just the... Give me your love!
That's all that's in my head! So,
- It's no good!
- It's no good.
Lifetime Showtime is competing.
It's competing.
Oh, they're rivals.
Yeah, it must be Nerissa's
demonic powers, right?
The other thing that comes to
mind, I think, the first,
- The first impression.
- The first impression?
Nerissa really likes to be physical
with us and the other element members.
I remember when we first saw her, it kind
of looked like she had made Biboo her toy.
- Tiny toy.
They were like stuck together.
Probably against Biboo's
will, but Biboo was just smiling.
And then, there was one
time, suddenly I think...
Just suddenly, out of nowhere,
Nerissa just Kabedon'd me!
Very casually.
My first kabedon, I tried really
hard to have a straight face,
But inside I was panicking.
It was too casual.
It was too casual, just all of a
sudden she's just like, heh heh.
Yeah, I was surprised.
Have you ever been
Kabedon'd, Ruffians?
Maybe? Maybe we'll have the
- opportunity to introduce you.
- Nerissa says she's sorry.
- She's sorry?
- Are you sure?
I was trying to be strong, but inside I was
like... You liked it though, didn't you?
No, no, no. Nerissa! Nerissa!
Me? Me?!
- No, no, no. Nerissa.
- Nerissa?
I wonder what was going
through Nerissa's head.
What was her motive?
Maybe she wanted to
just make you flustered.
Maybe. And,
Then I did the perfect thing.
I just had a straight face.
No reaction.
She did enjoy it, huh?
- But the other thing...
- I'm safe.
The other thing about Nerissa.
Her legs are very pretty.
Especially when she crosses them.
It was hard not to stare.
But I made sure you know,
I made sure to compliment.
Because I thought, maybe
that might make Nerissa happy.
She seems the type.
What? The type?
What does that mean?
The type to like those
kind of compliments.
It's a nice compliment.
If it's a nice compliment,
you say the compliment.
But yeah, she always is really helpful.
And you know, thinking about
all the other avid members.
I was really kind and it's like a big
bird that you can count on always.
- A big bird.
- A big bird you can count on.
It's important to have a
big bird you can count on, so...
And that's... Nerissa!
- Thank you!
I wonder, Ruffians, if
your first impressions
of the other Advent
members are similar to us.
Let us know with the hashtag
#FWMCMORNING, okay?
- Now for today's new corner!
- The start of a new corner! New corner!
It's Doggie of the Day!
Today we have... De-den!
We have this cutie!
He's the Doggie of the Day!
BAU BAU BAU!
You know, he's very strong.
Guard dog goals, I would say.
Look at his nose, it looks so good.
It looks like the PlayStation controller.
The PlayStation 2 controller!
I wanna touch it.
What is his name though?
Should we give him a name?
Let's give him a name then.
He looks like a fluffy to me.
But he looks fuzzy though, like his nose.
Give me a fuzzy. A fuzzy?
- Fuzzies.
- A fuzzy.
- That's his name now. Fuzzy.
- Wait, should his name be Fluffy or Fuzzy?
Ruffians, what do you think?
Is he more fluffy or more fuzzy?
- Fluffy or fuzzy?
- What a dog, right?
- Right?
- Dog goes!
Very beautiful.
Fluffy? Fuzzy?
Fluffy PlayStation?
This is a dog, not a PlayStation.
Wow, buzzy.
We'll call it buzzy for now.
But I wonder what his bark sounds like.
You know, he looks very royal.
So, you think it'd be more like a roar?
BAU! BAU! BAU!
- Like a BAUer?
- BAUer.
- A BAUer.
- Yeah.
I kind of feel like it'd be maybe
a bit more like... BAU! BAU!
Like a kind of like a husky softness?
Oh, like a deep, a deep bork sound?
A deep bork? Maybe. Maybe.
Yeah.
Do we give this fluzzy royal guard dog,
Do we give them a rating?
I think his rating is he's a very
good boy who loves you a lot.
We have competition, Moco-chan!
- Gotta do our best.
- Do our best!
Thank you for the Doggie of the Day!
Remember, we're always taking more
doggies of the day, so please send us some!
- Thank you!
And our next beginning
of another new segment.
Today, I Went For a Walk.
I Went On a Walk.
On a walk.
On a walk. I Went On a Walk.
Well, let's see what was this walk like.
Here's today's submission!
This looks like a very beautiful walk.
You know, all the clouds,
they look so fluffy, but
The blue skies, the grass is
green, the trees are lush.
Very peaceful for your heart.
I hope it wasn't too hot, but you know,
I think the cold tea probably
helped a lot too, right?
You know, sometimes when we go
on walks, we get really, really thirsty.
So sometimes as sort of
treat, we'll get one to share.
Right! You know, tea is a treat.
But it really is a treat.
It's a treat. It's tea!
But it's good to stay hydrated so make sure
you always drink lots and lots of water.
And sunscreen too!
Be like with Koicha as well.
Yeah, Koicha's good!
But yeah, sunscreen, and
watch out for cars, okay?
Cars, yeah.
Safety always.
Make sure you're always making sure
that you're safe in your environment, okay?
Thank you!
And next, a sudden
addition of a news segment.
We have... Question of the Day!
Quite a good question!
Question! "Is there anything you two
would like to try when you go to Japan?"
Is there anything you would
like to try when you visit Japan?
- There's a lot of things.
- There's a lot of stuff, but...
I think the first thing that
comes to mind though is...
Wanko soba.
- Wanko soba!
- Do you know what wanko soba is?
OK well, first, soba is buckwheat noodles.
Wanko soba is like a dish
from Iwate Prefecture, but
It's really just small servings
of soba noodles in your bowl,
And so you eat that, and
then there's a soba keeper
that will give you a new
bowl, and then you repeat.
It's kind of like a bit of a race.
Yeah, they're smiling, right?
Yeah, and Wanko soba is kind of like
a feeling, you know, it's like...
You're a dog and you're
really hungry, you know,
So you gotta eat fast,
fast, fast, fast, fast!
- Eat!
- Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum!
We've never tried wanko soba before.
I guess we don't really like being watched
while eating because we get nervous.
But we'll do our best to eat lots.
Like good puppies, okay?
And then afterwards, you know, you
can count how many bowls that you eat.
Yeah, you can do it with
your friends too, right?
How many bowls do you
think he's eaten though?
Oh, uncountable.
But Ruffians, have you had soba before?
Do you like udon or soba?
Yeah, udon or soba.
We're talking about wanko
soba, so I feel bad if I don't say
- that I like soba the best, but...
- You can eat 70?
- Soba?
- Udon?
Moco-chan, let's both say
it at the same time, okay?
- Udon!
- Soba!
It's different.
But I only like, I like udon
when it's really nice and chewy.
I like that udon too.
Sometimes there's like a thin udon and then
I'm like... It's not what I was thinking.
But it's good too!
Soba's good too though.
Soba's one of my favorite in Japan.
There's some really really
good soba places too.
I like to be able to have like
fresh udon too, you know?
There's lots of yummy things.
But, but, but!
Next! Next!
Our next stream, we will be playing...
Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion.
We thought it really looked cute.
It's like a cute scary, right?
Yeah, we were preparing.
It's a jumpscare mansion,
but you know... It's cute.
That's just one kind
of form of horror, right?
So we opened it up and
it already jumpscared us.
We had to both look away
from the screen and then...
But Moco-chan was like "ahh, maybe
not now, maybe I can't do this anymore."
I didn't want to close off the game 'cause
I thought it was gonna jump scare me again.
Yeah.
When do the jump scares happen?
When do they stop?
I guess that's the point
of a jump scare, right?
I hope it's more cute than
what I've experienced so far.
Yeah. So, we'll definitely need your help.
We need your help.
You better hold our paws, okay?
But even though you know it's a scary
game, we're really looking forward to it
Because we want to play
a game with you so bad!
We want to play a game!
We've been really happy to be able
to chat lots and lots, but I feel like...
We should play a game
sometime soon too, you know?
We'll be playing that later today,
so we hope you'll be there, okay?
Today!
- Today!
- Not tomorrow!
TODAY!
Actually, Moco-chan...
Can you, as a punishment,
Can you say "tomorrow" in your
best Ina-senpai impersonation?
Tomorrow!
I give it a B+.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Rate Moco-chan's "tomorrow."
But remember: Spooky's Jump
Scare Mansion is today today.
- "10 out of 10!" Ooh!
- 10 out of 10!
C minus?!
C minus.
It's good to be honest.
And before we end today, let's
have another peek at our schedule.
How about it?
De-den! Our schedule!
Don't forget, our first
Advent collab is coming up.
Our first game collab.
I'm really excited about it.
I can't wait to be able to be there
with Shiori and Bijou and Risu again.
I feel like it's been too long.
I really miss them.
We're gonna do our best
to protect all of Advent.
It's gonna be a bit scary,
but we'll do our best!
Actually, recently,
I've been feeling a bit...
Maybe sad, maybe like... ennui?
- Ennui?
- Ennui.
Now that we've debuted all we...
kind of have to share the Advent
members with everyone else.
And... somehow I feel
pretty complicated about this.
I'm not really that happy about it.
I don't want to share them!
It's a funny feeling.
Maybe it's not the most positive
feeling, but... We have to share them now.
Yeah, we're not gonna
keep them away from you.
They're free.
- That's okay.
- We're free.
And also, we have our first karaoke
stream at FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
It's coming up on Saturday.
Are you excited with us?
We're very excited.
I don't know if you're excited.
Is there anything you
want to hear us sing?
I'm always curious, you know.
It's our first first Welcome Party,
so I want to make sure that it's good.
Good set list.
And finally, do you
notice the "???" mark?
What is it?
- It's a good mystery.
- It's a mystery.
But you have to be there to find
out, so make sure you're there, okay?
Before we say BAU BAU for now...
We'd like to shout out to some of
our Extra Special Viewers today.
Ruffians, are you ready?
Kiyo Kiyo!
Do your best tomorrow! BAU BAU!
KSHMR!
BAU BAU!
Zokko! BAU BAU!
Tomshi! BAU BAU!
Nino! BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there,
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!